[Music]
there's no gas there's no petrol there
is nothing to eat there is no medicine
what can we do if this continues we will
have to jump into the sea
[Music]
we would like to tell the government
that whatever happened today they can't
stop tens of thousands of people joining
the struggle it is a joke if the
government thinks it can stop this
people's protest by using barriers tear
gas or shooting
[Music]
so
[Music]
sri lanka is not a dictatorship
this is a democracy and we will fight
for the rights of the people and we will
fight to protect democracy in our
motherland
[Music]
there's obviously a lot of wrangling
happening behind closed doors as we
speak late last night we heard that the
entire cabinet had submitted a clear
elective resignation
to the president that allowing the
president and the prime minister
gotaberraja parks and his brother
mahindra rajapaksa to reconstitute the
cabinet there have been a lot of
criticism about members about key
figures in that cabinet and some of the
coalition partners of the government had
basically proposed an interim
administration and one of the things was
a rework of cabinet
[Music]